pour terminer robert ménard bonsoir
robert
bon revers je suis ravi de pouvoir on va
pas se mentir malade est un fonds
s'était pas très bien entendu j'avais
fait une blague sur sur votre femme et
vous m'aviez traité de minable et je
vous excuse parce que entre temps c'est
con mais non mais parce qu'entre temps
j'ai compris que c'était une très belle
histoire votre rencontre avec votre
femme vous êtes rencontrés à bamako en
2010 vous étiez tous les deux venus
assister au sommet de la francophonie
vous en tant que patron de reporters
sans frontières est elle en tant que
responsable des fédérations
internationales des droits de l'homme
comme quoi ça tient à pas grand chose de
basculer de l'autre côté tu vois un m'a
fait mal digéré une touriste ait eu vote
fn voilà c'est ça non mais attendez
attendez non on dit que le racisme
augmente mais c'est faux c'est juste que
les français ont été très déçus du club
med
et honnêtement et honnêtement robert
depuis que trump a été élu on sait pas
ce qui peut arriver moi j'ai envie qu'on
s'entende bien mais oui mais non mais
c'est vrai
si ça se trouve c'est vous le prochain
président de la république tu vois ça
sera peut-être une république mais ça
sera peut-être le prochain non mais il
ya tellement de surprises en politique
si ça se trouve la meilleure chance de
la gauche en 2017 c'est benjamin biolay
et on ne sait pas encore
aujourd'hui tout peut arriver tu vois
avec tout ce qui se passe on peut plus
dire ça ne peut pas arriver parce que
franchement qu'est ce qu'on en sait
hollande a bien été élu président serbe
trump a été élu président karine le
marchand a fait une émission politique
steve est un livre sur la monarchie
qu'est ce qu'on en sait franchement non
mais
c'est vrai
alors robert comme 3 me fait passer des
messages forts vous avez fait une
campagne d'affichage pour l'arrivée des
migrants avec ce message il arrive voilà
et je trouve ça formidable parce que
cinq revers il a fait ça pour prévenir
les habitants de béziers parce que s'ils
veulent accueillir un petit migrants
chez eux au moins ils sont au courant tu
vois ils auront le temps de faire le
ménage pour les accueillir
convenablement mais c'est toujours
chiant du cese c'est les mecs qui
débarque à l'improviste et après c'est
toi qui passe pour un cadeau c'est
compliqué quand même tu veux je vous
rassure s'il arrive jusqu'à béziers les
migrants c'est que pour passer ils
s'arrêteront pages sont pas combattues
quitte pas mossoul pour béziers et
la bêtise n'a pas de limites je vous
propose de venir à béziers on en
reparlera porte que sur un plateau de
télévision grass les combats
béziers ou par câble à béziers banon
déjà j'ai pas tout et vaccin est pas
bien
faut pas être méprisant avec notre jeu
je connais plein de gens
méprisent assez facile ici que la chasse
soit sur les nerfs
dans un souci de réconciliation j'ai
décidé de vous écrire une petite lettre
robert
[Musique]
alors au début j'ai voulu mettre chez
robert mais comme je voulais pas que les
gens pensent qu'on le paye pour venir
sur ce plateau du coup je suis resté sur
robert j'avais aussi mon petit robert
mais comme il y avait un côté
dictionnaire
voulais pas que ça passe pour un truc
trop intelligent au risque de se faire
traiter de bobo gauchiste dont je suis
resté sur robert
[Musique]
robert robert et toi le maire de béziers
tu nous a bien
prouvé
que dans la vie il faut toujours croire
en ses rêves tu t'es dévoués en
reprenant ce poste car franchement à
part des emmerdes qui d'autre aurait
repris cette ville de
[Musique]
75000 habitants
des réformes choc et des décisions
fermes bientôt il y aura plus loin que
l'hérault et un jour toi aussi tu sera
connu dans l'univers comme le célèbre
adolphe sax elle est l'inventeur du
saxophone
non non non non robert attends attends
attends de faire [ __ ]
robert bon en fait
non non non c'est termine arrête toi il
s'allie européenne c'est ainsi
[Musique]
m
bon
bah les parties 1 comme quoi c'est pas
les meilleurs qui s'en vont les premiers
bons l'auront tu vas t'y connais moi
c'est bon pour ta carrière
[Applaudissements]
c'est un soir en tuf et robert mais la
hauteur
ouais bon alors je termine la lettre la
terminale est maintenant qu'il est là on
est tranquille donc donc je disais un
jour toi aussi robert tu sera connu dans
l'univers comme le célèbre adolphe sax
qui est l'inventeur du saxophone quand
même merci d'être revenu robert
et le mans deux parties voilà ce que
pour quelqu'un qui se dit ne jamais être
invités c'est la deuxième fois en moins
de six mois quand même que vous revenez
dont vous voyez finalement ici aux
restos du coeur ou chez l'abbé pierre il
ya toujours une place pour ceux qui sont
en galère
bravo c'est entendu la fin
6ème entendu
la question qu'on vous voulez tuer mais
ça pourrait passer deux ou trois oui
voilà c'est déjà un miracle que je sois
pas parti sur seloger.com j'ai très mal
vécu
qui était donc les questions cons que tu
irina soi-disant pas voulu vous vous
posez
bruno solo yvan le bolloc'h et bruno
ivan dans la pièce que vous jouez
l'heureuse élue ou fait la gueule parce
que l'un des personnage joué par david
brécourt est bizarre et le fait qu'il
ait joué dans sous le soleil ça ça vous
dérange pas non ça
robert ménard saïb et la wii alors
robert vous aviez annoncé vouloir lutter
contre les déjections canines en fichant
les chiens de la commune via des
prélèvements d'adr vous allez commencer
par les lévriers afghans
oui
si tu veux faire maintenant tu lève les
yeux au ciel comme ça pour terminer
faustine bollaert vous qui animait le
meilleur pâtissier à votre avis robert
ménard cuisineraient mieux les congolais
où les têtes de [ __ ]
à la bombe
amr
salut selon qui s'en va ouais voilà un
train dans 20 minutes 1 béziers c'est
pas tous les jours 100 ans de pro b nay
peut pas rentrer en stop par personne le
prends un bon niveau d'émission merci
c'était comme
d'ici là sur scène
woerth
thomas robail sa part très bien en tout
cas
quelque chose de 2,2 à propos de béziers
oui je voudrais en profiter parce que
j'ai plein de camarades de gitans ouais
quel est l'intérêt d'avoir sciemment
agitons c'est bien robert et bac ça
permet de dire du bien de la ville de
béziers voilà quand robert est parti
donc je voudrais adresser un salut
fraternel à la famille patrac la famille
baptiste la famille santiago la famille
reyes qui sont à baiser sur ces chers à
mon corps moi je prends une petite
pensée pour toutes ces poules qui se
font violer impunément
c'est bien robert très cinéma pour
abonder dans le sens où on se tape pas
confondre robert ménard et tous les
biterrois les habitants de béziers ya
des gens formidables moi j'ai tourné
dans cette ville c'est une ville que
j'aime beaucoup maintenant voilà il a
été l attendait cela nettoie voulez moi
là encore plus mais c'est une belle
ville béziers et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou